We're going to get started
because we have a very
short period of time together.
It's exactly 20 of 11.
So we have with us Carolyn
Wood from the now the Medical
School formerly the
Kennedy School and Monica
Higgins from the Ed School.
And I'm Nancy Kane from the TH
Chan School of Public Health.
And we're all educators.
We're all very much supporting
the educational mission
of our respective schools.
Sometimes against the grain.
Sometimes more with the grain.
And many of us--
I think all three
of us have been
in different parts of
Harvard in different parts
of our careers in education.
So what strikes
all us, I think, is
that although we want to do a
lot of focus on this-- a lot
of the conferences around
this instructor at the middle
of this circle, that context
that the instructor is in
has an enormous impact on
how well that structure can
perform.
And should we be thinking
of how to evaluate
the quality of the
decision making
that creates this context?
I mean, one colleague
looked at this and said,
oh, you're talking
about the culture.
Yes, but it's not an
immutable culture.
What are some of the decisions
that-- or the ways decisions
are made that
effect that culture,
that create that culture.
So that's what we wanted to have
this group be talking about.
And even thinking of
how to ask about it
was really quite a long process.
We really appreciate the input
of the HILT people and we've
all been going in
circles around this--
So this is from a public
health concept called
the socio-ecological
framework for health,
with a patient or the
individual in the middle,
but then there's all
these different influences
on the individual.
But we thought we'd sort of
steal from it a little bit
and apply it to
teaching and talk.
So what I'd like for
people to talk about
is how are decisions
made about these things
in your institutions?
What's your experience?
And what can be improved?
Where are we--
how can we come up
with a list of best practices to
improve the culture of teaching
and the likelihood of success
of teaching in our schools.
I'm going to very quickly.
In our school, we have a set
of students whose expectations
are that attendance is optional
and that they should be told
what to think, because they went
to, frankly, medical schools,
many of them.
And no offence, but that's where
a lot of them got their habits.
So just that alone has been a
real challenge for those of us
that believe in a
more interactive
and engaging and presence
and mind and body.
In terms of how
programs are structured,
you can have a program
that is actually
not built so that courses
build on each other
or that people are
overlapping or that they're
well-coordinated and
so the students get
the maximum benefit
out of whatever
you're doing as an instructor.
So things about how those
educational programs are
designed and coordinated
is another one
of the many things that can
effect the quality of what's
going on in the classroom.
School-wide policy.
We've all talked about
promotion criteria,
although that may not--
in our school, we find most of
our senior faculty are teaching
and some of that teaching
is highly variable.
But also how
teaching is paid for,
what kind of
classroom facilities
are out there for
you to teach in.
All kinds of different
types of decisions
that effect whether you can
actually teach in the most
interactive way possible.
How well your IT systems work--
your technology works.
Whether you have support to do
technology assisted learning.
And then external forces.
Carolyn and I were
having a great discussion
at one point about the
role that accreditation
plays in medical school, driving
so much of the context there.
And licensing exams,
whereas public health
doesn't have that
external pressure
to hit the targets and measure
that learning through passage
of the licensure exam.
So this is the topics
we wanted to talk about.
Maybe Carolyn, you want to make
a couple remarks, and Monica,
too, about what you observed.
And then we'd like
to let you loose
talking about the question that
you're sitting at the table of,
and maybe we'll have
to get your comments,
and then we'll make sure
we understand the question.
Sure.
So from my perspective, when
Nancy proposed this idea,
I found it really engaging.
I have spent more than a
decade at the Kennedy School
working to build the
teaching and learning unit
over there, the SLATE
program and the Case program.
And I think the Kennedy School
invested incredibly heavily
in supporting faculty to teach
in a broad array of ways.
It's very heterogeneous
curriculum.
And I think they
had a lot of success
in the elective curriculum
on an opt-in basis.
So individual
faculty working alone
in their classrooms in their
elective courses, which
constitute about 90% of
their course offerings,
chose to engage with this
incredible array of resources
that we provided.
But it Was a little bit tougher
to get really meaningful change
in the core curriculum.
So now having recently--
very recently-- joined
the medical school,
one of the reasons
that I chose to make
that move is I'm
really interested
in working at scale.
And the medical
school has decided
to do what I would describe as
a big bang change to the way
that they're teaching.
So it's not just individual
faculty opting in.
It was faculty working
together to define what
should our graduates
know and be able to do
at the end of four years
at Harvard Medical School.
And they basically
worked backwards
to redesign
competencies, courses,
and even change the pedagogy
across the board with a much
larger faculty than
the Kennedy School has.
And so for me, that was
a really inspiring move,
and I joined the team to try to
figure out how did they do it?
How do you make it successful?
And is there
anything there that's
replicable for other
parts of Harvard
or other parts of higher ed.
So that's kind of the
lens that I'm bringing.
Great.
So welcome, everybody.
My name is Monica Higgins.
So I've been at Harvard's
graduate school of education
for about 12 years now, but
before that at Harvard Business
School.
And I actually did my PhD work
where I spent most of my time
in the psych department.
So I've kind of gotten to see a
lot of different places, parts
of the university.
And one of the things
that strikes me--
so this is a learning
session, so we're
kind of building off of and kind
of tweaking each other's work.
When over at the
Ed school we like
to talk about the
instructional core.
So teacher, you know, students,
and content in this triangle.
Which, I guess, Nancy, we
might put in the middle, right?
Somewhere.
Maybe even put
students in the middle
and structures in the next ring.
But this triangle is so key
to everything that we do.
And then for us
at the Ed school,
when we think
about this, we have
this larger external
environment,
which is comprised
of all these rings.
But what's interesting at
the Ed school that's going on
that we really should echo--
I'm sorry.
What's going on
in the environment
that we need to echo
at the Ed school is
this real shift towards
thinking about how to recreate
an environment here in which
students are not just kind
of engaging in rote memorization
and so forth, but really
engaging in what we call--
some of the faculty
called deeper learning
and complex cognitive
thinking skills
and project-based
learning and all of those
that we're actually
enabling our own students
to go out and enact and
be professionals, right?
But then we need to
do the same thing.
Right?
So we can't sit and
lecture and so forth.
It's a lot more than
flipped classrooms.
I mean, we've gotten rid
of courses, in some cases.
Some cases, we have modules.
Some cases, we have labs.
Some cases, we are actually
consulting to the Children's
Defense Fund and so forth.
And we're doing-- we're
trying to really recreate
the environment that we
aspire for our students
when they leave the Ed school.
But then that creates
really interesting questions
as professional school,
which is how do you actually
evaluate teaching?
So professor has
gone from being used
to kind of a lecture-based
or PowerPoint,
et cetera, some a little
bit of flipped classroom,
but not that much to a
completely different model.
How do we evaluate that?
How do we teach--
how do we teach our faculty
how to change in that way?
How do we select faculty?
That's our biggest
issue right now.
We look at their course
evals, but that's
nothing-- has nothing to do
with what we want them to do
once they get to the Ed school.
So I guess what I'm
saying is we think
about this as kind of a mirror.
You know, what's
going on in k-12,
and how do we create that
and inspire our faculty
to follow the model
that they hope
their students will actually go
out and enact once they leave.
So that's why I'm
interested in the topic.
And you have three
specific questions.
Yes.
So at this point, we wanted to
really use our time together
to just foster a conversation
among you all about some
of the deeper dive
questions that
were in the session overview.
You So you have on
your table a document
that lists the three questions.
And you'll have a question
number on your table.
So we're going to ask each
table to discuss as a group
one of these three questions.
And we're going to have
about 20 minutes to do that.
We're going to ask each table
to identify one person to kind
of share and report out
the conversation that you
have had about your question.
So we'll have multiple groups
working on the same question.
So we'll-- when
we do the report,
I'll be able to get some
dialogue or interplay between
the various groups working
on the same question.
And then at the
very end, we're just
going to pull out a few themes.
And I want to just
give you a heads
up, just to close
out the session,
you each have an index
card on your table,
and we're going to ask you to
write down on the index card
one thing you've learned
at today's session
and one question
that you still have.
And we're going
to collect those,
type them up, and
then email out to you
the kind of collective
work of our group
today so that you can
use that as fodder
for further conversation.
We're also going to
share it with HILT
to inform their future work.
So we'll remind you at the
end on the index cards.
But now-- so questions.
If you're not at a table
that has the question
number that you want to work on,
now would be the time to move.
So question number one.
So if you're at a table
with question one.
What criteria are uses
to approve new courses?
How is course coherence
maintained across the degree
program over time?
What criteria are used
to retire courses?
How might the decision-making
process effecting-- processes
that effect what
course is offered
and how they can be improved?
One question.
That's question one.
Question two is how is the
value of teaching excellence
introduced to new faculty?
How is it reinforced throughout
the faculty member's career,
including after tenure?
And how might that
process be improved?
And then question three.
What carrots and sticks
and pressure points
are used to encourage excellent
teaching in our research
university setting?
How can they be more effective?
What are the challenges
to implementing
more effective measures?
Nancy and I worked some of
these questions in the past,
and some of them are
actually very difficult,
so we're dying to see
what you guys come up
with from your own settings.
So with that, make
sure that you're
at a table that's working on the
question you're interested in.
And why don't you begin
your conversations
after you establish
a rapporteur.
So I mean, I think given
that people kind of randomly
sat down at tables, it
would be terrific to benefit
from hearing from what the
table discussions were.
I know that you slopped over
into different questions.
That's fine.
And it's natural,
and it's normal.
And the questions
are interrelated.
And there are many
questions per question.
What we'd like to do
now is just make sure
that we hear from
each of the tables.
So there are eight tables.
And if somebody just
in terms of the --
they're pointing at each other's
friends can just give us some
highlights of the discussion
just for a couple of minutes.
I'm going to just track time,
and I'll just kind of give you
the signal if you're going on.
Or I'm being drawn in,
you can do that to me.
So let's start with this table.
So you all had the
first question.
[CHATTER]
[LAUGHTER]
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
Keith, did your table
want to get started?
And we'll come back then.
All right.
I'll take one for the team.
Just a couple of minutes.
We were the team-- one of
the groups that's lumped
into different questions.
But I think that
the challenge is
that we were highlighting
the fact that we all
had different structures,
different constituents,
different processes, protocols,
and different students
that we were trying to serve
for different organizations
and regulatory boards.
And so for answering a question,
it all worked very different
for each of us.
We needed to
contextualize who we were
and what some of our
motivations and guidelines were.
Also the fact that we also had
a different set of core courses
versus electives.
We also had a
different way in which
we vetted those or
different groups that
helped to support those.
And I love the fact that
we also kind of threw
in the wild, wild west
in terms of sometimes it
was very organic, and sometimes
it was far more structured
in that process.
What was the--
I'm sorry?
The approval of new courses
and what that looked like
and who taught those
and for how long.
And one thing that we kind
of touched on-- people,
please jump in if
I'm misspeaking--
but some of the
information that informed
our decisions about
new course offerings
or different curriculum
changes, maybe
different policies,
different what we're
hearing from marketing,
different employment
demands, student
surveys, and also
what lights up the
instructors and the faculty.
And how to keep all of
these different data
sets kind of in
check meaningfully.
Great.
I'm going to add one
thing since I hung out
with you guys a little bit.
One of the really interesting, I
thought, kind of back and forth
was asking employers
what they think.
But then it came up
at the table, what
do they think the students
need to be able to know or be
or do and so forth,
and then kind
of trying to map that back.
And then the
interesting question
that they talked about was well
is that even a good question?
I mean, do the employers know?
Maybe we should be
ahead of the game
and trying to
change that sector.
And so that was clearly
an interesting case.
Back to you guys.
Yes.
So similarly, just
trying to understand
each other's
contexts, and what we
found is the main thing
that came out, I think,
was around faculty autonomy.
So how decisions got made about
curriculum design and whatnot
may--
may or may not have been
within particular departments
or different faculties.
But ultimately
whether a course got
offered or not was based on
what the faculty wanted to offer
and how much it would
or wouldn't take away
from their own research time.
But that was also--
depends on the graduate
level or undergraduate.
So we also talked about
what it means for FAS
and how departments have
to navigate that with them.
And then how
sometimes those things
are tracked by a staff
person within the office--
within the department,
who says hey,
we need someone to
teach over here.
You also mentioned how
one of your takeaways
was the lack of transparency.
That if you are--
maybe if you're not a--
in the tenure line,
you may not really
even understand
the processes that
are happening in designing
or to build the curriculum.
I also distinguish between--
the difference between a single
course and a whole curriculum
and how those structures
might be different, even
within a single school.
Absolutely.
I don't even know--
transparency is part of it, too.
Sometimes it's just
information not
getting to the people who
are enacting the programs.
Right.
It's been decided,
and then all of sudden
we're having to make all
these adjustments to program
requirements, not to mention
get the word out to the students
that something's changed.
So that's an interesting
personal school challenge.
I also heard an
interesting discussion here
about what constitutes teaching.
So for example, is advising
part of teaching, or in HBS?
Writing cases is actually
considered part of teaching.
So that was also interesting.
And you guys also
had question one?
We did.
And we have a broad array.
So we had the school of
public health, Houghton excuse
me, Widener and Lamont
Library, medical school,
and we're from the college
in romance languages
and literatures.
And so the question of--
what I took from
what you said is
that people offer the courses
they want, more or less.
Sometimes there's been
a proliferation of them,
and they need to be
cut back a little bit
because there may be too many.
And the decision
there, different bodies
in the different --except maybe
the library may have a body
but you didn't mention it.
Different bodies within schools
that determine what's OK.
In our particular
department, once a course
is approved by a
committee, I can't
remember whose name is,
the educational something
committee.
They have to say--
no, it's not even a course.
It's a line of study.
But once they've approved
what makes a French major,
then the freedom is
within the department
to say what levels are.
And we do to try to have
a balance of courses
for undergrads and grads
where there's a progression.
But that isn't to say
that they're aren't kinks.
And one of the questions
that interests me,
which someone else
had brought up,
is how you address a course
whose faculty member--
it's a core course that repeats,
but it isn't drawing very well.
Because it's very delicate
to talk to a tenured--
right.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
And I think the
faculty who are tenured
feel that it's a
delicate discussion.
So that's a tough one.
Yeah.
Around evaluation when there
isn't generally evaluation.
Right?
Yeah.
OK.
Thank you.
So that was a
question one, which
are kind of what are
the different processes
and systems in place for
bringing a course on board
or retiring a course.
And so for question
two, it's just
about how the value
of teaching excellence
is actually even
introduced to faculty.
How is it reinforced.
So question two folks.
Can I take your table?
Thank you.
Sure.
So almost all of our group
comes from med school,
so I guess we're pretty
specific in that way.
But we talked a lot about how
new teachers coming in to--
from our perspective,
don't receive a whole lot
of introduction as far as
what teaching excellence is
or what's kind of expected.
We actually have a new
faculty member in our group,
so we actually had
a window straight
into kind of what she received
and how helpful that was.
So we talked about
that a little bit.
And then we also talked
about this kind of buy-in
from the leadership team
and for people overall.
We talked a little bit
about the promotion metrics
at the med school and how
within the promotion metrics,
every faculty member has to
teach for 50 hours a year,
but it's a little
bit ill defined
as to what those
teaching hours are
and what's considered teaching.
Is it actually
classroom teaching,
or is it teaching at the
bedside or one-on-one in a lab.
Where does mentorship
fall into that,
and should mentorship
be a separate category.
So we also talked about kind
of buy-in from leadership
as far as their
values in teaching.
So there is this 50
hour requirement,
but a lot of people
kind of dread
that component and make that
clear to people under them
that they don't want to
be doing those hours.
And so if that's the culture
that's coming from the top,
how can that encourage
other people to kind of buy
into the psyche of
it, that teaching
is good and wanting to
learn more about it.
And overall, we
kind of just talked
about how the ability to teach
is not necessarily something
you're born with and that
there are skills we can learn.
And so how are ways we can
start incorporating more of that
into as well.
Wonderful.
Great.
And you all as well
had question two.
Yeah.
We talked about how
graduate students are often
a major venue for instilling
the value of teaching, and that,
for example, the work at the
Bok Center in providing support
for doing that at
the department level
and for assisting graduate
students with both awareness
of their teaching and of
the Bok Center services.
And how there would be an ideal
for doctoral students to have,
longitudinal development
around teaching
in the time of their
degree program.
And what would it take
to work towards that
in a particular department?
That would probably
look different
in different disciplines
and different departments.
We talked about, we know
that there are evaluations,
but it's not necessarily clear
whether department chairs
work with that
content or feedback
or provide feedback from
that, but that itself
would be a signal
that could be very
powerful in a
specific department.
We didn't have any
particular insight into it,
but it struck us
as an opportunity.
Whether it happens or
not says something,
no matter what the
experience is like.
And we also talked about
how despite the fact that--
we talked about mentoring
programs and the ability
for faculty to
mentor each other.
But then again, it's not
clear the extent to which
that ultimately gets
focused on research agenda
and how to really be productive
with your research agenda as
opposed to teaching.
So again, there's not a lot
of structure to make sure.
There are some opportunities
for where this can happen.
We were less clear
on whether that
actually is happening or let
alone the effectiveness in--.
Right.
I like how you opened
up that up for us
to think about in
terms of opportunities.
One last opportunity,
we were talking
about how many
faculty members often
found their passion
in their research
because they had
a great teacher.
Right.
And so how could
we reconnect them
to that early experience
as a motivator.
Nice.
Yes.
Interesting.
Great.
And were you three tables--
I can't see.
We're question two as well.
Great.
Thank you.
So we ended up, I think, having
an interesting discussion
as the spectrum of offerings.
So we had the business school.
I'm from the business
school, and Nancy's
from the business
school, where we
have I think the
most significantly
hands-on new teacher training.
So we have a three
day compulsory program
for new faculty to come through
where they observe classes
being taught to
them as students,
they teach to themselves
and they get feedback on it,
and then are introduced to
the Christensen Center, which
is a administration
supported and funded
voluntary group of five
people who are purely there
for their teaching development.
To the opposite end of the
spectrum at the law school,
where they're given a
mentor when they come in,
but it's more self-forming
groups around academic interest
areas and research
areas where they kind of
get together and talk about the
teaching of that little moment.
And it's not that
it's not happening,
but it's more informal.
So the question is
whose responsibility
is teaching excellence, then?
Is it administrative, as a
school and as a department,
that we will set
these things in motion
and give them financial support
and administrative support?
Or is it the faculty?
So one of the
things I shared was
when the Christensen Center
was first established,
there was questioning
amongst the faculty
that a center like that
would allow and give
a pass to a tenured faculty
to miss their mentoring
opportunities and basically
abdicate their responsibility
to the junior faculty.
To not have to take part
in that process of teaching
junior faculty because somebody
else is going to do it.
And that they don't-- that the
burden is off the shoulders
of the senior faculty, but
that their voices are just
as important.
So as a center, we learned
early to make those voices come
into the work of the center.
And how do we keep that.
But that is then our
administrative department's
burden of maintaining
that ecosystem.
So it becomes its own beast.
And the third leg to the
stool then is from the library
perspective, if
you've got suddenly
a new technology and
a new way of using
maps and data and
analysis and you're
training doctoral
students but not faculty,
do you not have a
responsibility to the prestige
of the university as a whole
to be demanding that faculty
understand the latest and
greatest for their own good
and for the students' good.
So it's this three-way
conversation of how do we--
we don't disagree that
excellence is needed.
It's who is ultimately
responsible.
That's a great question.
Such a great question.
And how we establish
that in the community
that we are in [INAUDIBLE].
So one of the things
that became important
when we were discussing is that
the business school faculty's
backgrounds is pretty diverse.
So you can have non-MBAs,
Harvard MBAs, other MBAs,
practitioners from 20
years, newly minted PhDs,
and that does require
some leveling of the field
if you're going
to go in and teach
900 students a core course.
But at the law
school, he was saying
that everybody-- everybody
has a law degree, so everybody
has been through a law degree
program, and to the point
where it's either
Harvard or Yale has
a law degree [LAUGHTER].
To the point where you already
have an established set
of rules versus
when you don't --.
Yes.
Selection versus development.
Great.
All right.
This is very helpful.
Thank you.
I really appreciate it.
OK.
We're moving on
to question three.
So question three was
what carrots and sticks
and pressure points are used
with projects on teaching.
We're kind of looping
into that realm.
I'm pretty sure when we
hear from these tables
that we'll move back the
first question as well.
But tell us what you
were talking about.
How about this table right here?
So we also touched on the
diversity in the approaches
and carrots and sticks
and pressure point
across different
parts of Harvard.
So the difference of like
meeting at the medical school,
like some real
carrots and sticks
for why teaching is important
there when it's not as much
of a focus in their practice,
whereas at the ed school,
where people are
teaching about teaching,
and so therefore may want to try
new things in their classroom
or be exposed to what is
the latest technologies
or approaches or practices
in the classroom.
And we talked a little bit
about exposure to opportunities.
So I think there, it sounds--
you know, it's interesting
to get this wide perspective,
because there's sort of a
different level of thinking
about teaching
for a new faculty.
At the ed school, I was--
I was hawking the Instructional
Moves program, which is really
trying to get the ed school to
be a leader, since our focus is
on teaching and education,
to be a leader in sort
of dissecting the science
of teaching for all four
universities.
And you should all
check out the website.
[LAUGHTER]
But part of the idea there is
to really get teaching down
to these bite-sized chunks
so that, you know, it's
great to have a three-day
teacher development training,
but this is sort of an
ongoing resource So.
If someone-- say someone reads
their teaching evaluation,
and they're feeling
kind of downtrodden,
and they want to do
something over the summer
or over a break or something.
This is a resource
for people to say,
I'm going to try something new
in the lecturing interactively
category, because I got some
low results on my lecturing
feedback.
So that's nice resource there.
And then we also talked
about the difference
between intrinsic
motivation, people
who want to be good teachers or
feel like that's an area they
need to improve
versus extrinsic,
like Tamara, who teaches
freshman writing at FAS
and has a Q score
next to her name.
And that is, like, the
difference between her
continuing her job or not.
And one of the things that came
up at the end of our discussion
was the idea of these
less monumentous end
of course evaluations and
more of things like this.
You know, like this
constant feedback.
And I know at the
ed school, I work
on a lot of the online
course development,
and we have weekly
course evaluations
for the online courses,
mostly because we
don't have as much--
well, we don't
have any face-to-face
interaction with the students.
And so having a weekly
evaluation where
we're just taking the pulse of
the classes or they're saying
I found this particular
reading offensive.
I found that
lecture not helpful.
And it's less of--
what Tamara was
saying is sort of how
they're feeling in the
moment when they're
writing the full course
evaluation versus this dialogue
about teaching evaluation
during the course.
Great.
Thank you.
I might throw out
a general question
that I think will be
somewhat controversial.
Yes.
If I said to the group--
I polled the group, and said
do you think that everybody
on the factory can be
a great researcher,
my guess is people'd say no.
Or everybody who
enters the faculty
is going to be a
great researcher.
Why do we assume everybody
can be a great teacher?
Or do we assume that?
And yes, we have lots of
faculty development programs
to make you a better
teacher than you may be.
But shouldn't we
aspire just to have
the great teachers with our
students and really rethink--
I mean, that's something we've
been doing at the med school.
We've talked about core faculty.
But that fundamental
question, why do we
assume everybody can
be a great teacher?
Because I think that
demeans teaching.
I mean, what really great
educators are about.
And I think --.
[COUGHING]
I think that's a
terrific question.
Better versus great.
But certainly, I think we're
in the process of learning.
Obviously, we're all
in part teachers,
so we do believe that people
can change and grow and learn.
And then it kind of depends in
part on what your threshold is
for great, which might
vary depending --.
Well, the medical
school has three tracks.
Yes.
So that gets to the carrots
and sticks kind of thing,
too, right?
So what we are saying, we are
prioritizing one over the other
because you can't be here as a
researcher without being great.
You know, again, how
do you define great?
I don't know.
By their peers, et cetera.
Well, and every school does
have different criteria.
Promotion criteria.
Which I heard some
tables talk about.
In fact, Judy, you
were talking also
about the importance
of measurement
and understanding for what
audiences and that oftentimes
their measurement
doesn't necessarily
serve their purposes
that we need it to serve.
I want to hear from
this last table,
and then if we want to come
back also to this question,
we can do it in
the time remaining.
Yes.
Well, I think we
have seven minutes,
so take a couple for your table,
and then we'll bring it back.
Sure.
We talked for a while,
and what we sort of
realized after
talking for a bit was
that in a lot of ways,
the incentives that we saw
are actually the exact opposite
of what you would want in that
for the most part,
you know, you're
not going to get promotion
based on your teaching.
You can only maybe not
get promoted if you
have truly abysmal teaching.
And so what that does
is it incentivizes
people to explicitly
not try something
that might be new and risky.
Right.
And then we, from
there, went to this idea
that we also recognize that
often good teaching yields
bad evaluations because it's
harder for the students.
And so actually, our evaluations
are-- and we talked about this
early this morning--
are not actually
evaluating what we need
them to be evaluating.
That's great.
That's exactly what
this table was saying.
So what we recognized is that
you have to align those things.
So you have to actually
create evaluations
that evaluate what you
want, but then also take it
into account in a way that sort
of shows what your values are.
And right now, it shows
that actually, you
know, good teaching is not
valued over passable teaching,
because you're not going
to really get much benefit
from excellent teaching.
And so then the
incentives end up
being more intrinsic incentives.
Or we talked a little bit,
just from my experience,
in the medical school,
you end up with--
you get graduate students
doing the teaching..
Which is very
important, actually,
but also ends up sort of
being intrinsic or separate
from any sort of
structural system.
Great.
I love this discussion
around incentives.
So we have five minutes left.
I don't mind if you
end with questions.
I think that that's
actually good.
Don't forget we need time
to fill out the index
cards for the last minute.
Yeah.
You guys can fill out
while you're listening.
Do you guys have a couple
of things you want to share?
Or do you want to take
a couple of questions?
I think the incentive question
is really interesting.
It does vary across schools.
I remember when I got
a teaching award when
I moved over to the
ed school, and I
said is this a good thing?
Because I was coming
up for tenure,
which is so strange
to have to as.
So your point about
the ed school--
I mean, it's just
very interesting,
because our incentives
are not always clear.
Why is it a bad thing?
Because it means you're not
doing your research [LAUGHTER]..
Oh, I'm sorry.
I thought that was obvious.
[LAUGHTER]
I think a couple
questions would be great.
And then I have one
big observation,
but I would love to
hear from others.
One of you had-- two
of you had hands up.
In the back.
I was just going to follow
up on the incentives thing.
It's not only that great
teaching isn't incentivized.
It's actually the reward
for great teaching
is more teaching.
Absolutely.
And then your time.
And sometimes I think bad
teaching or just barely
passable teaching is
incentivized because, honestly,
scholarship is where promotion
and standing in the community
is, and honestly, should be.
We are a research institution.
And so if there's
a problem, it's
not like we can just say, oh,
we'll realign our incentives.
Teaching is really
where it's all at.
Because scholarship is.
And there's always so
many hours in the day.
I know.
Just something to keep in mind.
I had a different
question, but now I'm
thinking about this
question that's
the balance of research
and teaching, which
is part of the incentives.
I'm not sure-- it
seems like we're
living during a pretty historic
period, where we are rethinking
what knowledge is, whether
knowledge should be carved up
into what we call
fields or disciplines
or this 19th century German
model of the research
university.
It seems like we're still taking
that for granted at least in,
I would say, in FAS.
I'm not sure about
other schools,
so I only speak to that.
And you know, I know plenty
of students personally
who were baffled by
the implicit acceptance
that there is a link between
research and teaching
and that scholar teachers, it
feeds each other, as opposed
to say taking somebody who
actually can communicate
and can get people to
understand a concept,
even if that person is
not the best in the field
or contributing new knowledge.
And I wonder if that--
uncoupling that or
maybe even questioning
that as a kind of article
of faith in the research
university maybe will
help us understand
that there are different people
who need different things.
People who've committed
to a concentration,
but then maybe
never go back to it.
Go off and do something
completely different.
As opposed to a
graduate student, who
is committing to it for life.
I know a lot of freshmen
who could care less, really,
about the research element
of their professor's life
and don't understand why the
teaching is not prioritized.
And I just want
to build on that.
I want to push back a
little bit on just the depth
of the focus on
research to the point
where it crowds out teaching.
We had a dean at the Kennedy
school that used to say,
we're a school.
You have to remind people
that we're a school.
We are not a think tank.
There are think tanks out there.
Harvard University
is not one of them.
So if we're going
to accept students,
we actually do
have an obligation
to do a good job in
building their skills
and their progress
towards mastery.
And I actually wanted to
draw a parallel to the idea
that President Faust raised
about creating synergies
between your research
and your teaching
to creating synergies
about kind of being
a strong leader or a strong
citizen and your teaching.
And I think that at the med
school, one of the things
that struck me most
when I got there
was that the way
that they've define
their competencies
for doctors has
very little to do with factual
knowledge of hard science.
I would say 80% of the
competencies fall around things
like, can you ask
the right questions?
Can you empathize
with your patient?
Are you open to
their perspective?
Are you going to give
them a care routine
that they can actually
comply with, based
on their socioeconomic status?
So these are leadership skills.
These are communication skills.
These a human skills.
And in my view, those
things are as or more
important than any factual
knowledge or research
knowledge that might come out.
So I would just pose
another alternative.
I think we are out of time.
Just-- my last observation.
I teach strategy,
organizational strategy.
And the one thing
that always strikes me
in these conversations
is how rarely one
says we have educational
goals we want to reach
and we have a process for
making sure that we reach them.
And so much of
education is indeed
this sort of organic
entrepreneurial individual
faculty interest, but
does that measure up?
Does that sum up
to where we want--
what we want our
students to learn?
And the environment
at medical school
is far more required
to go that way because
of the external demand.
But in these softer
fields where there
aren't these external
demands, it's not clear to me
that the educational
goal-setting process
is one that is linked to the
rest of what happens in terms
of what gets offered and
how programs are designed
and what courses.
So our --my school
really doesn't
have a strategic planning
process for education.
But I think-- I don't
know about other schools,
but I think that's one of
the missing links for making
all this sort of get and give
people reason for why they
teach what they teach
that may or may not
be linked to research.
But this was a
fantastic conversation.
It was great to hear from so
many different perspectives.
Please spend time thinking
about what one thing
you learned that
you hadn't already--
Or one question you could ask.
You could add a question.
It's a sign of a good session
if you leave with questions.
So thank you.
And we'll share back
to you by email.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]